Efe'nin balkonundaki sardunya, o sabah ilk çiçeğini açmıştı.
Bir arı geldi ve çiçeğin tam ortasına kondu.
Efe eğildi.
Arının bacakları sarı tozla kaplanmıştı.
Arı kalktı ve iki saksı ödedeki çiçeğe kondu.
Efe bir yerden alınıp başka yere bırakılan o tozu merak etti.
Çiçekli bitkilerin üreme organı çiçeğin kendisidir.
Efe bir çiçeği dikkatle incelemeye karar verdi.
Elindeki çiçeği sapından tutarak kaldırdı.
Çiçek sapı, çiçeği bitkinin gövdesine bağlayan kısımdır.
Bitkiden gelen suyu ve besini çiçeğe o taşır.
En dışta yeşil, küçük yapraklar vardı.
Bunlara çanak yaprak diyoruz.
Çiçek tomurcukken onu sararak korurlar.
Ayrıca fotosentez yaparlar.
Onların içinde renkli ve kokulu yapraklar duruyordu.
Bunlar taç yaprak.
Çiçeğe rengini ve kokusunu veren kısım.
Renk ve koku boşuna değil, böcekleri ve kuşları çağırırlar.
Efe taç yaprakları usulca aralıyınca içerideki organları gördü.
Ortadaki kalın yapının çevresinde ince saplı olanlar diziliydi.
İnce saplı olanlar erkek organ.
İki kısımdan oluşuyorlardı.
Uçlarındaki keseciye başçık denir.
Polenler, yani erkek üreme hücreleri başçıkta üretilir.
Başçığı taşıyan ince sapada sapçık diyoruz.
Ortadaki kalın yapı ise dişi organdı.
Üç kısımdan oluşuyordu.
En üstteki geniş uç dişicik tepesidir.
Yüzeyi yapışkandır.
Konan polen oraya tutunur.
Altındaki uzun boruya dişicik borusu denir.
Polenin aşağı ilerlediği kanal budur.
En dipteki şişkin bölüm yumurtalıktır.
İçinde dişi üreme hücresi, yani yumurta bulunur.
Efe arının bıraktığı sarı tozu şimdi anlamıştı.
Polenlerin başçıktan dişicik tepesine taşınmasına tozlaşma denir.
Bu taşımayı rüzgar, su ya da böcekler yapar.
Bir polen dişicik tepesinin yapışkan yüzeyine tutundu.
Oradan dişicik borusunun içine doğru yol aldı.
Yumurtalığa ulaştı ve yumurta ile birleşti.
Bu birleşmenin adı döllenmedir.
Döllenme sonucunda tohum oluşur.
Yumurtalık da gelişerek tohumun etrafında meyveyi oluşturur.
Efe saksının dibinde geçen yılın kurumuş meyvesini buldu.
Meyveyi ikiye ayırdı.
İçinden bir tohum düştü.
Şimdi sıra o tohumun yeni bir bitkiye dönüşmesindeydi.
Şimlenme.
Efe iki kavanoza ıslak pamuk serdi ve birer fasulye yerleştirdi.
Tohumun çimlenmesi için üç temel şart vardır.
Unutmamak için parolamız S-O-S.
S sıcaklık demek.
Ortam ne çok soğuk ne çok sıcak olmalı.
O oksijen demek.
Tohumun hava alması gerekir.
İkinci S su demek.
Tohum şişip kabuğunu ancak suyla açar.
Efe kavanozlardan birini karanlık dolaba koydu.
Üç gün sonra dolaba açtı.
Karanlıktaki tohum da çimlenmişti.
Çünkü çimlenme için ışık ve fotosentez gerekmez.
Tohum ilk besinini kendi içindeki depodan karşılar.
Işık ancak yeşil yapraklar çıktıktan sonra gerekli olur.
Efe fideyi sardunyanın yanına dikti. Arı yeniden geldi.